a British woman has been revived from a
six-hour cardiac arrest after developing
hypothermia 34 year old Audrey Sherman
was hiking in Catalan Pyrenees in
northeastern Spain with her husband when
the weather turned bad but it was the
low temperatures which saved her life by
protecting her body and brain from
deteriorating I'd like to say Audrey
joins me now from Barcelona
Audrey fantastic to see you and to see
you looking so well after this ordeal
just tell me when you first realized
something was wrong we'll to be honest I
have amnesia I don't remember the hike
at all so I didn't really know anything
was wrong until I woke up in the
hospital surrounded by sand very worried
looking people I think my husband had
the worst of that that trip yeah I was
going to say not least of all your
husband who had realized something was
wrong you were you were having trouble
sleeping and moving during this hike in
the Pyrenees that the weather had
deteriorated you were starting to lose
consciousness and he called for help and
then what happened he thought for help
when he could our phones and boats
turned off from the cold during the
worst of the snowstorm
but fortunately we'd actually spend with
friends who had already made it to the
ski station ahead of us and so they'd
already contacted Mountain Rescue and
before my husband was able to get in
touch with them so the emergency
services knew that we were lost and were
able to to get our helicopter mobilized
and come out to find us quite quickly
once they knew where we were and really
I think that the coordinated efforts
that that mountain rescue team put in in
hindsight is absolutely incredible by
the time you got they got to you your
husband said he couldn't feel her pulse
couldn't feel any breath he couldn't
feel a heartbeat at all you were
transferred to hospital and there
what um the doctors put me onto a
machine which is cooling ECMO machine
and it's as I understand it it's really
state-of-the-art technology and it's
probably the only thing that could have
saved my life I was very lucky to be
taken to that hospital what the Machine
did was my blood was being taken
external to my body and it was serving
his heart and lungs it was oxygenating
my blood and removing the carbon dioxide
while simultaneously warming my blood so
they were able to to bring me back up to
a more stable temperature and make sure
that my body wasn't deprived of oxygen
in the meantime and how long did this
process take Audrey I think by the time
I arrived at the hospital the timeline
is based on my husband's whatsapp
messages to our friends the emergency
services so I think it was about three
hours and ten minutes from when I lost
consciousness and stopped breathing
until I arrived at the hospital and then
it was another three hours at the
hospital more or less I'm not sure
exactly until they were able to restart
my heart using the defibrillator but
they kept me on the machine for I think
about forty or forty four hours in total
just to make sure that I was stable and
that my brain had recovered enough for
them to detach me and let me I mean
talking to you Audrey it's quite
remarkable to hear what you've gone
through just a month ago how are you now
I feel really back to normal it's it's a
month ago today that I came round that I
woke up and my recovery has been much
more rapid than the doctors expected
there aren't that many documented cases
of recovery from this kind of severe
accidental hypothermia and cardiac
arrests at this length and obviously the
technology is really it can proved a lot
and the team that rescued me and the
doctors did
right so I've been able to recover very
quickly I feel almost as good as new
my hands have some problems with nerve
damage there's a very small price to pay
for what could have been so much worse
and on an emotional level how do you
deal with the knowledge of what you've
been through but also your husband
having witnessed at all it's definitely
worse than it is for me I think I didn't
really take on the seriousness of what
I'd been through until I was definitely
until I was out of hospital and able to
read more and ask more questions and I
so I've had time to absorb it slowly and
take on each new piece of information as
it comes you know he's gonna have to
live with the memories of that day and
he didn't know that this technology
existed he thought I was dead and he's
doing okay he's very strong I think he's
going to be all right but it's
definitely a lot and I saw a clip of you
speaking earlier you're not you're not
ruling out a return to the mountains
Audrey I hope not I love them and I
wouldn't like to let this take that away
from me from us okay Audrey Sherman
thanks very much indeed for talking to
us really a medical phenomenon there
Audrey Schumann who was revived after a
six hour cardiac arrest thank you